Buddha's farther is visited by an angel
who tells him that his son is going to
grow up to be the greatest temporal
profane ruler of the world has ever seen
or a great spiritual leader and his
father.
Being a pragmatic and conservative man
decides that there's no possible way.
I'm going to allow my son to take the
ambivalent road of spiritual
enlightenment.
I'm going to allow him to fall
completely in love with the world so
that he will remain attached to his
domain.
So prior to Buddha's birth,
his father constructs a great city with
walls around it and inside that city he
removes all signs of pain,
frustration,
and disappointment.
Any sign of ugliness,
the end aids,
the only people that are allowed to
exist within the city or those who are
in perfect mental and physical health
who are paragons of beauty and virtue.
And the idea that lurks behind that
archetypal story is that when a father
has a child,
the his moral obligation is to shield
the developing consciousness of that
child from contact with any of the
horrors of life that could provide the
child with an experience too traumatic
for that developing consciousness to
apprehend so because it's an archetypal
story,
it relates to the development of all
people,
not just the redemptive savior,
and that's the motif that the Buddhist
story initially follows.
A good father makes his child fall in
love with life by enticing that child
into a direct relationship with all that
life has to offer.
So Buddha grows up within this walled
garden.
It's unselfconscious paradise,
but precisely because he's been shielded
to this degree and allowed to mature.
His consciousness continues to expand
and the world outside the boundaries
that his parents have established for
him starts to attract his attention.
Now we know already that the forbidden
fruit,
right?
The lawyer of what's outside the walls
is something that human beings just
can't keep their mangy little paws off.
Right?
We are absolutely uncontrollably curious
and the best way to make sure that we
investigate something is to lay down a
stricture that says whatever you do
under whatever circumstances,
never look there,
right,
and then the automatic systems that
underlie our orienting and that motivate
our seeking experience are constantly
pulling our attention precisely to that
forbidden spot,
compelling us to investigate exactly
that which has been forbidden.
So because Buddha is a consciousness
developing in a healthy manner,
he immediately becomes curious about
what lies beyond the the limits that
have been established with him and he
makes a decision to go outside of
Paradise.
Right?
Which seems a particularly ridiculous
thing to do given that in principle he
has everything he could possibly want
inside the walls,
but then again we have the troublesome
notion of the original sin of Adam,
right?
Which is that if any of you were offered
a forbidden fruit,
again under circumstances mythologically
equivalent to those that are obtained in
the beginning,
you'd immediately reach your hand out
and take it.
Because what we haven't got for human
beings is always far more compelling
than what we have got.
So Buddha goes outside the walls,
but his father,
who's a good father,
although somewhat conservative,
decides he's going to rig the game a
little bit so it gets rid of everybody
that's diseased or unhappy or
uncomfortable or ugly rolled or anything
that could possibly disturb the Buddha,
any lines,
the streets with flower waving women and
puts pedals on the road and census,
son out into gilded chariot.
But the gods who are lurking around
right,
the troublemaking gods who represent
chaos and disorder in the unknown decide
to stand in front of Buddha.
A sick man who hobbles unsteadily
interview and Buddha asks,
is his retainer precisely what this
phenomena represent sound?
His retainer says,
well,
you know,
human beings like you,
sincere human are subject to the
deterioration of these physical powers
in an arbitrary way.
And this man is one person who's being
so affected.
And so buddha is completely disenchanted
by his exploratory move out into the
terrible unknown and runs back into the
castle walls and shuts the door and is
perfectly happy to think of nothing for
months.
But then as his anxiety habituates and
his curiosity grows,
he can't stand the notion of never going
outside the walls again and outside.
He goes again and this time where after
his father prepares the route ever so
carefully,
the godsend insight and old man who
hobbles interview and mood,
it looks at him in shock and horror and
says to his retainer,
just precisely what's going on here.
And His retainer says,
well,
that's an old man and everybody gets old
and you're going to get old too.
And that's the way of all humanity.
And that's the point at which voted.
Self consciousness expands not to only
include the possibility of degeneration,
but to include the temporal horizon
that's characteristic of life.
And he finds that so terribly shocking
that he runs back into the castle and
shuts the walls down and plays with his
friends for another six months,
maybe a year till his anxiety.
Finally habituates.
And he goes out one final time.
And this time the godsend,
a funeral parade for him and he sees his
first dad body.
And this is such a terrible shock to him
that he can't even go back to the
castle.
So his father prepares for him a great
party in the woods near the castle full
of nude dancing.
Women who are perfectly willing to
flaunt themselves into offer themselves
to him.
But Buddha is so absolutely
catastrophic,
really shocked by this notion of
emergent death,
that he can't take any pleasure
whatsoever and what's being offered to
him.
And he leaves the kingdom once and for
all.
And you think,
well,
that's exactly what happens to you when
you grow up.
Right?
If you're reasonably well socialized and
properly looked after,
then your curiosity gets the better of
you and you keep going out into the
world until what year parents have
established for you is no longer
sufficient for you.
And as a consequence of that movement
own into the world,
you find out all sorts of things
characteristic of your own life that not
only your parents can't precisely
explained to you,
but even the broader formal structures
of your culture have a very difficult
time handling.
And when you finally do encounter such
realities and allow their effect on you
to fully manifest itself well then
you're finally independent and you no
longer can return home,
but from that point forward,
you are also burdened as Adam is
burdened when he loses his Paradise Hill
unselfconscious snus with the full
revelation of what it means to be
limited and alive.
So what happens to Buddha as a
consequence of this revelation,
he becomes an apprentice and the
chronicles of the Buddhist adventure are
careful to say that he becomes the
world's most proficient practitioner of
Sam [inaudible],
which was a philosophical precursor to
yoga and then to yoga so he masters all
the positions and the asanas until he's
disciplined physically to an almost
unlimited degree.
And then he decides that he'll adopt a
stance of world renunciation,
which is also something he's a
remarkably good at,
and he starved himself until the chronic
lewis say he resembles nothing so much
as a pile of dust and then having
exhausted all the disciplinary
structures that his sophisticated
culture has to offer him,
but still not precisely finding the
answer that he's looking for.
He retreats into the forest,
a place of the unknown and sits himself
at the base of a tree underneath the
tree.
He's visited by visions and temptations.
The first vision is an essentially
erotic one life itself,
camps him back out of his self conscious
state into the domain of pure physical
pleasure,
a perfectly reasonable temptation,
right,
and one that's powerful enough so that
Hindu philosophers say,
b,
as their churches and cathedrals are
covered with erotic drawings.
If you can't get past the erotic
drawings into the church,
that's the domain that you should still
inhabit,
right in the dawning phases of life at
least till middle age.
That's the appropriate motive being to
be enticed and seduced by the physical
pleasures that life has to offer,
but in the final analysis,
those are not sufficient to solve the
problem of emergent self consciousness
and so the angel of death visits him and
offered him the opportunity to exist
permanently in a state of Nirvana.
Very,
very interesting twist on the story
because you have to wonder,
given the association saved between
suicidality and the notion of paradise
that exists underneath that.
If what Buddha isn't being offered by
the angel of death is in fact death and
the cessation of all the problems of
being regardless,
he rejects that attains enlightenment
briefly and then decides to return to
the world to share what he's discovered
with all of suffering humanity.
The idea being that the Buddha who is
the awakened or enlightened one,
is capable of attaining a transcendent
state,
but also knows fully that because human
beings have a shared social aspect,
it is not possible for any one person to
attain redemption until all people
attain redemption.
The reason being that it's very
difficult to be transcendent and
enlightened when you see someone who's
sick lying in a ditch.